10h ce n'est laissé à la porte la seule
façon de mettre la main sur les
chocolats de chloé cette année c'est de
les avoir commandé en ligne
les paquets sont prêts à être livrés
quand on a commencé la production de
pâques jusqu'à la crise on avait produit
effectivement un quart de ce qu'on
produit habituellement ce qui explique
aussi que ça soit parti si vite sur
notre site internet quand on l'a quand
on a ouvert les commandes en ligne
normalement la boutique déborderait de
clients mais on a dû dire non à
plusieurs sans connaître les priorités
du premier ministre legault jeu bonne
eux
on dit que le lapin par d'abord fait
partie du service essentiel en plus
immunisés donc les enfants vont pouvoir
recevoir leur championnat du chocolat et
des fleurs bien sûr un monsieur c'est
justement parce qu'il travaille fort
plus faciles à trouver dans les
épiceries ces jours ci ce sera une autre
histoire pour les fleuristes en moindre
on sent qu'ils sont ouverts
par contre on va arriver à faire mille
raisons le ce week-end heureusement qu
est-ce qui vous a souri finalement est
la boutique en ligne en fait nous elle
est ouvert depuis un an donc sur notre
site internet les gens peuvent faire
leurs commandes
puis on offre la livraison gratuite donc
ça nous permet de continuer de survivre
pendant ce temps là y'a bracciali toutes
les contrats dits états même l'église
s'apprête à célébrer la plus importante
fête de la liturgie catholique de façon
inhabituelle le matin de pâques
l'archevêque de montréal célébrera la
messe à 8 heures 30 à la cathédrale
marie reine du monde est à peu près une
quarantaine de paroisses à montréal qui
était déjà avait déjà un site web ont
déjà une page facebook donc qui a régi
cm sont pas qu'on appelle à huit clos
avec les distance appropriée
c'est ce qu'on fait ici ça va être
diffusé en direct
aux arts les cloches des églises
sonneront à l'unisson
peut-être par facetime virtuellement mai
sinon j'irai pas rendre visite à
personne c'est sur dronne virtuel et
mais y aura pas de chocolat ni de fleurs
je pense donc joyeuse partie du petit
minois est en période de confinement des
fleurs le chocolat les petites douceurs
ont probablement plus d'importance ici à
nourrice despatie radio canada montréal